A splash of fresh water will reach the depths of your heart. Those mighty blue waves can propel you forward or they can calm and soothe. Coast to Michigan coast. Simply feel the flow in the moment. And let those vast lakes, rivers and streams create everlasting memories. Jump right in and let fresh wash over you in Pure Michigan. Keep it fresh at Michigan.org. Or on our website.
一捧清凉的泉水将触及你的心灵深处。那些汹涌的蓝色波浪可以推动你前行，也可以让你平静舒缓。从密歇根州的一岸到另一岸，只需感受当下的流动。让那些广阔的湖泊、河流和溪流创造永恒的记忆。在纯净的密歇根，纵身跃入，让清凉洗涤你的身心。在Michigan.org或我们的网站上保持清新。
The afternoon of Saturday, September 27, 1969. Almost three months after the murder of Darlene Farron in Napa, California. 21-year-old Joanne and her two friends made their way into California's Vaca Mountains. They went into a parking lot south of their destination and pulled their car into park. After gathering their belongings, they prepared to make their way down to Lake Berryessa. The 23-mile-long human-made reservoir was a popular recreational spot for swimming, fishing and water sports. It was a warm afternoon and the three young women were planning to do some sunbathing. As they exited the vehicle, another car caught their attention.
1969年9月27日，星期六下午。距离加利福尼亚州纳帕市达琳·法伦被谋杀案发生近三个月后。21岁的乔安妮和她的两个朋友前往加州的瓦卡山脉。她们在目的地南侧的一个停车场停好车。收拾好随身物品后，她们准备前往伯耶萨湖。这个23英里长的人造水库是游泳、钓鱼和水上运动的热门休闲场所。那是一个温暖的下午，三位年轻女性计划去晒晒太阳。当她们走出车门时，另一辆车引起了她们的注意。
A late model two-door blue Chevrolet sedan with California plates drove into the parking lot from the southern side. It passed the trio, but then began backing up to the empty spot behind their car. The driver continued reversing until the Chevrolet's rear bumper was almost grazing the bumper of the women's car. Then he stopped and switched the engine off. He didn't get out. As Joanne and her friends walked past the Chevrolet, they caught a glimpse of the lone driver inside. Sitting silently behind the wheel was a well-built white male who looked to be about 40 years old, with black hair parted to the left. The women continued onwards to the lake and settled by the shore.
一辆后期款的双门蓝色雪佛兰轿车挂着加州车牌，从南侧驶入停车场。它经过了三人，但随后开始倒车进入她们车后的空位。司机继续倒车，直到雪佛兰的后保险杠几乎擦到她们车的保险杠。然后他停下车，关掉了引擎。他没有下车。当乔安妮和她的朋友们走过雪佛兰时，她们瞥见了里面唯一的司机。坐在方向盘后面沉默不语的是一个身材魁梧的白人男性，看起来大约40岁，留着向左分缝的黑发。女人们继续向湖边走去，并在岸边安顿下来。
They stripped down to their bikinis and began soaking in the sun. About half an hour later, they looked up and noticed a man standing approximately 40 feet away amongst the trees. The women recognized him. It was the driver of the Chevrolet. Now that he was standing outside, he looked tall, perhaps between six foot and six foot two. He was dressed in dark trousers and a matching shirt, a odd choice for the sunny waterfront setting. The enormous size of the lake meant there was more than enough room for visitors to spread out. This alone made the man's proximity unusual, but it was the way he stared at the women that was most unnerving. Deciding it was best to ignore him, the young women didn't speak to the man, but they glanced up intermittently to check if he was still there.
她们脱掉外衣露出比基尼，开始享受阳光。大约半小时后，她们抬头注意到一个男人站在大约40英尺外的树丛中。女人们认出了他。正是那辆雪佛兰的司机。现在他站在外面，看起来很高，大约在6英尺到6英尺2英寸之间。他穿着深色长裤和配套的衬衫，在阳光明媚的湖畔环境下，这是一种奇怪的选择。巨大的湖泊意味着游客有足够的空间分散开来。仅这一点就让这个男人的靠近显得不同寻常，但最让人不安的是他盯着女人们看的方式。决定最好无视他，年轻女性们没有和那个男人说话，但她们不时抬头查看他是否还在那里。
Every time they cast their gaze in his direction, he averted his eyes. After about 30 minutes, he finally stepped out of the shadows of the trees and dabbled down to the lakefront. He got within about 20 feet of the women, before traipsing up a hill and disappearing into the distance. When the trio returned to their car 15 minutes later, both the man and his vehicle had vanished. A short while later, Clifford Rayfield and his 16 year old son were further along the shoreline when they noticed the man in dark coloured clothing watching them. He stood on the incline of a hill, halfway between the nearby road and the lake. That's odd, Clifford thought. The man wasn't carrying a fishing pole, camping equipment or a firearm per hunting.
每次她们看向他的方向，他都会避开目光。大约30分钟后，他终于从树影中走出来，漫步到湖边。他走到离女人们大约20英尺的地方，然后爬上一座小山，消失在远方。15分钟后，当三人回到车里时，那个男人和他的车都不见了。不久之后，克利福德·雷菲尔德和他16岁的儿子在更远处的岸边，注意到那个穿着深色衣服的男人在注视着他们。他站在山坡上，位于附近的道路和湖泊之间。克利福德心想，这很奇怪。那个男人没有带鱼竿、露营装备或打猎用的枪支。
What's he doing out here then? Clifford wondered. The man moved closer. He was somewhat stocky and not very nimble, but he walked with purpose. When he was within 100 yards of the father and son, he stopped abruptly and stared at them. Six uncomfortable seconds passed. Then, just as suddenly, he turned around and headed back up the hill towards the road. It seemed as though he'd been agonising over something, but then changed his mind. Confused by the encounter, Clifford looked to his son.
那他在这里做什么呢？克利福德心想。男人走近了。他身材有些壮实，动作不太敏捷，但他走得很有目的性。当他走到离这对父子100码以内时，他突然停下来盯着他们。六秒钟令人不安的沉默过去了。然后，他同样突然地转过身，朝着山上的路走去。看起来他似乎在为什么事情苦恼，但随后改变了主意。对这次遭遇感到困惑，克利福德看向他的儿子。
The teenager happened to be holding his rifle. It seemed as though Clifford was holding his rifle. Clifford looked to his son. Clifford looked to his son. Clifford looked to his son. Clifford looked to his son. Oblivious to the strange man disturbing other Lake Berryessa visitors. 22-year-old Cecilia Shepard and 20-year-old Brian Hartnell took in their peaceful surroundings.
那个少年正好拿着他的步枪。看起来克利福德拿着他的步枪。克利福德看向他的儿子。克利福德看向他的儿子。克利福德看向他的儿子。克利福德看向他的儿子。22岁的塞西莉亚·谢泼德和20岁的布莱恩·哈特内尔沉浸在宁静的环境中，完全没有注意到那个打扰其他伯耶萨湖游客的奇怪男人。
They had arrived at the lake earlier in the afternoon. The two students were good friends who'd previously dated. Cecilia had recently transferred to another university and had stopped in at her old college for a visit. When she bumped into Brian there, the pair decided to spend the afternoon together. A last-minute change of plans led them to the lake. Brian parked his white Volkswagen Carmen gear by the side of Knoxville Road. He and Cecilia gathered up a blanket and a deck of cards, then ambled along a narrow dirt trail towards the water. After walking for about a quarter of a mile, they saw a sandbar that provided access to a small, grassy island.
她们下午早些时候到达了湖边。这两名学生是好朋友，以前曾约会过。塞西莉亚最近转学到了另一所大学，顺道回母校参观。当她在那里偶遇布莱恩时，两人决定一起度过这个下午。最后一刻的计划改变把他们带到了湖边。布莱恩把他的白色大众卡曼吉亚停在诺克斯维尔路边。他和塞西莉亚拿上一条毯子和一副扑克牌，沿着一条狭窄的土路向水边漫步。走了大约四分之一英里后，他们看到一个沙洲，可以通往一个小小的草地岛屿。
They walked across and spread their blanket under the shade of a large oak tree near the shoreline. From this idyllic spot, they had the perfect vantage point to admire the lake. Cecilia lay with her head on Brian's shoulder and they reminisced about old times. Two hours passed with nothing to disturb their privacy except for an occasional boat sailing across the lake's calm waters. It was nearing 6.30pm when all of a sudden they heard a rustling sound from some nearby bushes. Brian asked Cecilia if she could see what was making the noise. She looked over. The heavy-set man was standing a short distance away, watching them.
他们走过去，在岸边一棵大橡树的树荫下铺开毯子。从这个田园诗般的地方，他们拥有欣赏湖景的绝佳视角。塞西莉亚把头靠在布莱恩的肩膀上，他们回忆起往事。两个小时过去了，除了偶尔有船只驶过平静的湖面，没有任何东西打扰他们的隐私。快到下午6点30分时，他们突然听到附近灌木丛中传来沙沙声。布莱恩问塞西莉亚是否能看到是什么发出的声音。她看过去。那个身材魁梧的男人站在不远处，注视着他们。
He was white, approximately 200 to 225 pounds and between 5'8 and 6' tall. As Cecilia watched, the man stepped behind a tree and disappeared. She told Brian, who assumed the stranger was merely looking for an isolated spot to urinate. Nonetheless, he told Cecilia to keep an eye on him. Suddenly, she squeezed Brian's arm and cried out. Oh my god, he's got a gun. Cecilia and Brian stared in shock as the man strode towards them, pointing a handgun in their direction. Dressed in dark trousers and a windbreaker, the man's face was concealed by a dark hood that covered his entire head, shoulders and part of his torso.
他是个白人，体重约200到225磅，身高在5英尺8英寸到6英尺之间。当塞西莉亚看着时，男人躲到一棵树后消失了。她告诉布莱恩，布莱恩以为那个陌生人只是在找一个僻静的地方小便。尽管如此，他还是告诉塞西莉亚盯着他。突然，她紧紧抓住布莱恩的手臂尖叫起来。天哪，他有枪。塞西莉亚和布莱恩震惊地盯着那个男人大步向他们走来，用手枪指着他们。男人穿着深色长裤和防风夹克，脸被一个覆盖了整个头部、肩膀和部分躯干的深色头套遮住了。
Holes for his eyes had been cut into the hood and he wore a pair of clip-on sunglasses over the top. A neat white crosshair symbol was carefully painted across his chest and hanging from the right side of his belt was a large sheathed knife. I'm on my way to Mexico, he revealed. I escaped from Dear Lodge Prison in Montana. Brian peered through the exposed eye holes in the man's mask and noticed sweaty brown hair stuck to his forehead. He thought the man sounded young as though he was between 20 and 30 years of age and he didn't come across as well educated. He also spoke with a slight draw that was strangely familiar. Brian explained that he didn't have any money but would help in any way he could.
头套上剪出了眼睛的孔，他在上面戴了一副夹式太阳镜。胸前精心画着一个整齐的白色十字准星符号，腰带右侧挂着一把带鞘的大刀。我正在去墨西哥的路上，他透露道。我从蒙大拿州的迪尔洛奇监狱逃出来的。布莱恩透过男人面具上露出的眼孔看去，注意到汗湿的棕色头发粘在他的额头上。他觉得这个男人听起来很年轻，大约在20到30岁之间，而且看起来不像受过良好教育。他说话还带着一种奇怪的熟悉口音。布莱恩解释说他没有钱，但会尽力提供任何帮助。
He offered to hand over his wallet and car keys, but the man didn't take them. In an attempt to diffuse the situation, Brian nervously tried to engage the hooded man in conversation. At one point, the man reholstered his weapon, but he wasn't interested in being reasoned with. It was clear he had a specific purpose in mind. Like face down on the ground, I'm going to have to tie you up, he said. He removed several lengths of plastic washing line that were hitched to the left side of his belt and handed them to Cecilia. You tie the boy up, he demanded. Cecilia did as she was told.
他提出交出钱包和车钥匙，但男人没有拿。为了缓和局势，布莱恩紧张地试图与这个戴头套的男人交谈。有一次，男人把武器重新插回枪套，但他并不想讲道理。很明显，他有特定的目的。他说，趴在地上，我得把你们绑起来。他从腰带左侧解下几段塑料洗涤绳，递给塞西莉亚。你把那个男孩绑起来，他命令道。塞西莉亚照做了。
The man hogtied Cecilia himself before checking Brian's restraints to make sure they were tight enough. He then bound their ankles together. Noticing the man shaking, Brian asked if he was nervous. Yes, I guess so, he replied. Since the beginning of the ambush, Brian had suspected that the man's gun wasn't loaded. Now that he and Cecilia were both restrained, he wasn't so sure. He asked the man who pulled out the clip in response, confirming there were bullets inside. He then reached into his belt and pulled out a bayonet style knife with a long sturdy blade.
男人亲自把塞西莉亚五花大绑，然后检查布莱恩的束缚，确保它们足够紧。接着他把他们的脚踝绑在一起。注意到男人在发抖，布莱恩问他是否紧张。是的，我想是吧，他回答。从伏击开始，布莱恩就怀疑男人的枪没有装子弹。现在他和塞西莉亚都被束缚住了，他不太确定了。他问男人，男人回应时拔出了弹夹，确认里面有子弹。然后他伸手进腰带，拔出一把带有长而坚固刀刃的刺刀式刀具。
Brian felt terror surge through his body upon realizing this wasn't going to end well. He begged the man to stab him first so he wouldn't have to watch Cecilia being hurt. He began stabbing Brian over and over in the back six times in total. Brian was flooded with shock. He lay prone in a total daze, unable to react. Cecilia started screaming frantically. The man turned to her and launched a frenzied assault. He stabbed her in the back before rolling her over and repeatedly stabbing her in the torso.
布莱恩意识到这不会有好结果，恐惧涌上心头。他恳求男人先刺他，这样他就不用看着塞西莉亚受伤。他开始反复刺向布莱恩的背部，总共六次。布莱恩被震惊淹没了。他俯卧着，完全处于恍惚状态，无法做出反应。塞西莉亚开始疯狂尖叫。男人转向她，发动了疯狂的袭击。他刺伤了她的背部，然后把她翻过来，反复刺向她的躯干。
He launched his knife into her chest, breasts, groin and abdomen, grunting and breathing heavily as the attack intensified. When Cecilia stopped moving, the man calmly walked away from the scene. He headed back towards the road where his victims White, Volkswagen, Carmen, Gia was parked and took out a black marker. On the driver's side door, he drew a large crosshair. Then scribbled a series of words and numbers set out in several separate rows. He concluded his note with two final chilling words. By knife. Ronald Fong was fishing in Lake Berryessa with his nine-year-old son when he heard two voices screaming for help.
他将刀刺入她的胸部、乳房、腹股沟和腹部，随着攻击的加剧，他发出咕哝声并大口喘气。当塞西莉亚停止移动时，男人冷静地离开了现场。他朝着他的受害者停放白色大众卡曼吉亚车的路边走去，拿出一支黑色记号笔。在驾驶座一侧的车门上，他画了一个巨大的十字准星。然后潦草地写下了一系列分几行排列的文字和数字。他在纸条末尾写下了最后两个令人毛骨悚然的词。用刀。罗纳德·方正带着他九岁的儿子在伯耶萨湖钓鱼，这时他听到两个声音在尖叫求救。
The cries sounded as though they were coming from a small island nearby. Ronald circled his boat approximately 100 yards from the island and switched off the motor. He could faintly make out a young man and woman on the shore, but it was too far away for Ronald to tell whether their pleas were serious. He ultimately dismissed it as a gag. But 15 minutes later, he could still hear the screams. Ronald decided to approach the island and cautiously called out to ask what was wrong. As he drew closer, he saw Brian Hartnell leaning his head against Cecilia Sheppard and swaying from side to side. Both were soaked in blood.
哭喊声听起来像是从附近的一个小岛上传来的。罗纳德驾驶他的船在离岛约100码处绕行，并关掉了引擎。他隐约能辨认出岸边有一男一女，但距离太远，罗纳德无法判断他们的求救是否当真。他最终认为这只是个恶作剧。但15分钟后，他仍然能听到尖叫声。罗纳德决定靠近小岛，谨慎地喊话询问出了什么事。当他靠近时，他看到布莱恩·哈特内尔把头靠在塞西莉亚·谢泼德身上，左右摇晃。两人都浑身是血。
The pair had merely been playing dead in the desperate hope their attacker would leave. Brian explained that they had been stabbed and robbed. Horrified by the shocking scene, Ronald immediately piloted his boat to the nearby resort where he was staying to alert the authorities. With help now on the way, Cecilia and Brian managed to wriggle loose from their restraints. Both struggled to remain awake as blood continued to seep from their wounds. Brian's hands and feet were completely numb, but he was able to gather enough strength to stand up. He kissed Cecilia, telling her, I'm going to get help. On the verge of unconsciousness, Brian started walking towards the road.
两人只是在装死，绝望地希望袭击者能离开。布莱恩解释说他们被刺伤并抢劫了。被这令人震惊的场景吓坏了，罗纳德立即驾驶他的船前往他所住的附近度假村报警。随着救援人员赶到，塞西莉亚和布莱恩设法挣脱了束缚。随着血液不断从伤口渗出，两人都努力保持清醒。布莱恩的手脚完全麻木了，但他还是积攒了足够的力气站起来。他吻了塞西莉亚，告诉她，我要去求救。在失去意识的边缘，布莱恩开始向路边走去。
Instead of focusing on the realization that he could die, he told himself not to give up and focused on pushing on. I'm not satisfied with my personal life, Brian thought. This is no way to end it. Slowly, pain started to slip through the shock. His vision soon went black and he had to lie down. He made several more attempts to move, but eventually collapsed not far from the road. All he could see were the trees around him, blurred into an indistinguishable haze. Then he heard a sound. It was the engine of a truck drawing closer. Park Ranger Dennis Land was driving en route to the location where fisherman Ronald Fong and his son had witnessed the young couple in terrible distress.
他没有专注于自己可能会死的念头，而是告诉自己不要放弃，专注于继续前进。布莱恩心想，我对我的个人生活不满意。这不是结束的方式。慢慢地，疼痛开始穿透震惊。他的视野很快变黑，不得不躺下。他又尝试了几次移动，但最终倒在离路边不远的地方。他所能看到的只有周围的树木，模糊成一片无法分辨的朦胧。然后他听到一个声音。是一辆卡车引擎靠近的声音。公园管理员丹尼斯·兰德正开车前往渔民罗纳德·方和他的儿子目击那对年轻夫妇处于极度痛苦中的地点。
Approximately 300 yards from the road, Ranger Land found Brian Hartnell lying in the grass, his torso covered with blood. Ranger Land helped Brian to his truck and Brian directed him to the scene of the attack. By the time Ranger Land reached Cecilia Shepard, she was in an immense amount of pain. She had six stab wounds in her back and five to her front, the largest of which was 10 inches long. She was rocking back and forth on all fours, moaning. He was a man with a hood. His face was covered. It hurts. It hurts. At 7.40pm, the switchboard at the Napa Police Department lit up as a call came through. 70 minutes had passed since the attack at Lake Beriesa.
在离路边约300码处，兰德管理员发现布莱恩·哈特内尔躺在草地上，躯干上满是鲜血。兰德管理员帮助布莱恩上了他的卡车，布莱恩指引他前往袭击现场。当兰德管理员到达塞西莉亚·谢泼德身边时，她正处于极度的痛苦中。她的背部有六处刀伤，前胸有五处，其中最大的一处有10英寸长。她四肢着地前后摇晃，呻吟着。他是一个戴着头套的男人。他的脸被遮住了。好痛。好痛。晚上7点40分，纳帕警察局的总机亮起，一个电话打进来。距离伯耶萨湖袭击事件已经过去了70分钟。
I want to report a murder. No, a double murder, the mail caller said calmly. They are two miles north of Park Headquarters. They were in a white Volkswagen Kalman gear. The caller continued, ignoring questions. I'm the one that did it. He then placed the receiver down instead of hanging it up, so the call remained connected. Officer David Slate kept speaking into his phone, asking whether anyone was there, but there was no reply. Passing traffic could be heard in the background, along with what sounded like female voices. Officer Slate contacted the phone operator to see if the call could be traced.
我要报告一起谋杀案。不，是一起双重谋杀案，打电话的男子冷静地说。他们在公园总部以北两英里处。他们在一辆白色大众卡曼吉亚车里。打电话的人继续说道，无视提问。是我干的。然后他放下听筒而不是挂断，所以通话保持连接。大卫·斯莱特警官对着电话继续说话，询问是否有人在，但没有回应。背景中可以听到过往的交通声，还有听起来像是女性的声音。斯莱特警官联系了电话接线员，看是否能追踪到这个电话。
He was informed that the caller had used a pay phone. The operator would keep the line open as she attempted to find out where the call had originated from. Meanwhile, radio news reporter Pat Stanley was listening to his police scanner for possible stories. He overheard Officer Slate saying that a suspicious call had been made from a pay phone somewhere in Napa, and that the caller hadn't hung up properly. Pat decided to drive around town looking for the phone in question. Near a car wash on the corner of Main Street, 27 miles from the crime scene at Lake Beriesa, he spotted a phone booth. Inside, the pay phone's receiver was dangling down.
他被告知打电话的人使用的是公用电话。接线员将保持线路畅通，同时试图查明电话的来源。与此同时，广播新闻记者帕特·斯坦利正在监听他的警察扫描仪以寻找可能的新闻。他无意中听到斯莱特警官说，一个可疑电话是从纳帕某处的公用电话打出的，而且打电话的人没有正确挂断。帕特决定开车在城里寻找那个电话。在距离伯耶萨湖犯罪现场27英里外的主街拐角处的一家洗车店附近，他发现了一个电话亭。里面，公用电话的听筒正悬挂着。
Pat approached the phone and began shouting into the mouthpiece, asking if Officer Slate could hear him. When Officer Slate responded that he could, Pat provided the location. Two officers were dispatched to the area. They didn't notice anyone suspicious, nor were there any footprints or tire marks nearby. They photographed the phone booth and processed it as a crime scene, finding seven latent fingerprints, three latent palm prints, and one indistinct print. At Lake Beriesa, officers had found Brian's Volkswagen parked on the side of the road, a short walk from where the couple were attacked.
帕特走近电话亭，对着听筒大喊，询问斯莱特警官是否能听到他的声音。当斯莱特警官回答说可以时，帕特报出了地点。两名警官被派往该地区。他们没有发现任何可疑人员，附近也没有脚印或轮胎痕迹。他们对电话亭进行了拍照，并将其作为犯罪现场进行处理，发现了七枚潜在指纹、三枚潜在掌纹和一枚模糊的印记。在伯耶萨湖，警官们发现了布莱恩停在路边的甲壳虫汽车，距离这对夫妇遇袭的地方只有很短的步行路程。
Its doors were locked, and it didn't look as though anyone had attempted to break in. However, someone had used a black marker to write a message on the driver's side door. It began with a crosshair symbol, followed by the city name Vallejo, and vertical rows of numbers. The discovering officer immediately recognized these as significant dates. First was December 20, 1968, the date that the Zodiac murdered David Faraday and Betty Lou Jansen. Next was July 4, 1969, when the Zodiac attacked Darlene Faran and Michael Majo. The third and final date was the current one, September 27, 1969, followed by the time of 6.30, and the words, by knife. Upon seeing this final date, the police officer felt a wave of horror wash over him.
车门锁着，看起来没有人试图闯入。然而，有人用黑色记号笔在驾驶座车门上写了一条信息。它以一个十字准星符号开头，后面跟着城市名称瓦列霍，以及垂直排列的数字。发现此事的警官立即认出这些是重要的日期。第一个是1968年12月20日，即黄道十二宫杀手谋杀大卫·法拉第和贝蒂·卢·詹森的日期。接下来是1969年7月4日，当时黄道十二宫杀手袭击了达琳·法兰和迈克尔·马乔。第三个也是最后一个日期是当天，1969年9月27日，后面跟着时间6点30分，以及“用刀”这两个字。看到这个最终日期，警官感到一阵恐惧涌上心头。
It seemed that Cecilia Shepard and Brian Hartnett were the latest victims of the Zodiac killer. His instincts were confirmed when the handwriting on the car was compared to the known Zodiac letters. It was a match. Several witnesses who'd been at Lake Berryessa that afternoon spoke of seeing a man lingering around the shoreline prior to the attack on Brian and Cecilia. Police believed this was the Zodiac. When collated, these reports depicted a heavy-set white man of average height, wearing dark-colored clothing. He had spent hours traversing the hills around Knoxville Road. It appeared that the Zodiac was on the hunt for solitary vehicles parked in the area.
看来塞西莉亚·谢泼德和布莱恩·哈特内尔是黄道十二宫杀手的最新受害者。当车上的笔迹与已知的黄道十二宫信件进行比对时，他的直觉得到了证实。完全吻合。那天下午在伯耶萨湖的几位目击者提到，在袭击布莱恩和塞西莉亚之前，看到一名男子在岸边徘徊。警方认为这就是黄道十二宫杀手。汇总这些报告后，描绘出了一名身材魁梧、中等身高、穿着深色衣服的白人男子。他在诺克斯维尔路周围的山丘上徘徊了几个小时。看来黄道十二宫杀手正在该地区搜寻单独停放的车辆。
He would pull up behind them, then go searching for the vehicle's owners. He'd first done it to the three young women who went sunbathing, but left without confronting them for reasons unknown. He then came across Clifford Rayfield and his son. It was possible he'd left them alone after being spooked by the sight of their rifle, or because he preferred his victims to be male-female couples. About 20 feet to the rear of Brian's Volkswagen were some tire prints believed to have been left by the Zodiac's vehicle. At least two of the wheels had an exceptionally worn tread, indicating an older, poorly-maintained vehicle that spent a lot of time on the road. Latent fingerprints lifted from the exterior of the Volkswagen didn't match anyone in police records. Several distinct footprints were spotted leading to and from Brian's car.
他会把车停在他们后面，然后去寻找车主。他曾对那三名去日光浴的年轻女性这样做过，但出于未知原因，他在没有与她们对质的情况下离开了。随后他遇到了克利福德·雷菲尔德和他的儿子。他可能在看到他们的步枪后被吓跑了，或者是因为他更喜欢男女情侣作为受害者。在布莱恩的甲壳虫汽车后方约20英尺处，有一些轮胎印，据信是黄道十二宫杀手的车辆留下的。至少有两个车轮的胎面磨损异常严重，表明这是一辆老旧、维护不善且经常在路上行驶的车辆。从甲壳虫汽车外部提取的潜在指纹与警方记录中的任何人都不匹配。在通往布莱恩汽车的路上发现了几个清晰的脚印。
They were approximately 13 inches long, with a parallel bar tread design on both the heel and sole. Plaster casts of matching footprints were taken throughout the area, including one in the sand 100 feet from the point of attack. This one also showed a circular design in the instep area of the print. The pattern was from a wing walker shoe. Wing walkers were government-issued footwear worn by Air Force and civilian personnel. Their design allowed the wearer to walk on airplane wings without causing damage. It was determined that the Lake Berryessa print had been made by a military-sized 10.5R boot. Wing walkers were manufactured in Philadelphia before being shipped to Utah.
它们大约13英寸长，脚后跟和鞋底都有平行条纹设计。在整个区域采集了匹配脚印的石膏模型，包括距离袭击点100英尺处沙地上的一个。这个脚印的足弓区域也显示出一个圆形设计。这种图案来自“翼行者”（Wing Walker）鞋。翼行者是空军和文职人员穿着的政府配发鞋类。它们的设计允许穿着者在飞机机翼上行走而不会造成损坏。经确定，伯耶萨湖的脚印是由军用10.5R码靴子留下的。翼行者鞋在费城制造，然后运往犹他州。
Military bases throughout the country would then place orders for the boots and sell them on site. The closest base to the crime scene was the Travis Air Force Base, located 25 miles east of Napa. Purchase records indicated that the base had ordered and sold roughly 100 pairs of size 10.5 boots to personnel over the past 13 months. Unfortunately, buyers' details weren't available for these sales. Another 500 to 1000 pairs had also been sold at the base's separate surplus store. Of those customers able to be traced and tracked down, none were arrested for crimes associated with the Zodiac. Brian Hartnell and Cecilia Shepard were both rushed to the hospital in critical condition. Cecilia lapsed into a coma on the way.
全国各地的军事基地随后会订购这些靴子并在现场出售。距离犯罪现场最近的基地是纳帕以东25英里的特拉维斯空军基地。购买记录显示，该基地在过去13个月里向人员订购并售出了大约100双10.5码的靴子。遗憾的是，这些销售的买家详细信息无法获取。基地单独的剩余物资商店也售出了500到1000双。在那些能够被追踪和找到的顾客中，没有人因与黄道十二宫相关的罪行而被捕。布莱恩·哈特内尔和塞西莉亚·谢泼德都被紧急送往医院，情况危急。塞西莉亚在途中陷入了昏迷。
She died two days later without ever regaining consciousness. But, like Michael Majo before him, Brian miraculously survived. As he recovered, detectives stood vigil outside his hospital room, worried that the Zodiac might learn of the young man's survival and attempt to pay him a visit. Once Brian was well enough, he provided a detailed account of his terrifying encounter with the Zodiac killer. The Lake Beriesa stabbing was in stark contrast to his previous attacks at Blue Rock Springs Park and Lake Herman Road, which appeared to have been more opportunistic. Michael Majo said that when he and Darlene were approached, the killer fired into their car without saying a word.
她在两天后去世，始终没有恢复意识。但是，像之前的迈克尔·马乔一样，布莱恩奇迹般地活了下来。在他康复期间，侦探们在他的病房外守夜，担心黄道十二宫杀手可能会得知这名年轻人幸存的消息并试图去“探望”他。一旦布莱恩身体状况好转，他就详细讲述了与黄道十二宫杀手那次可怕的遭遇。伯耶萨湖的刺杀事件与他之前在蓝岩泉公园和赫尔曼湖路的袭击形成了鲜明对比，后者似乎更具机会主义色彩。迈克尔·马乔说，当他和达琳被接近时，凶手一言不发就向他们的车开火。
In the Lake Beriesa attack, the killer had spoken openly. The difficulty lay in knowing whether or not to trust what he'd said. The killers claimed that he'd escaped from Deelodge Prison seemed like a cover, but police still considered whether Montana could be significant to him. He had also admitted to being nervous. Was the Zodiac not the confident killer he portrayed himself to be? The answer to that question and many others remained a mystery. What was known was that he was becoming increasingly cruel and violent.
在伯耶萨湖的袭击中，凶手公开说话了。困难在于不知道是否应该相信他说的话。凶手声称他从迪洛奇监狱逃脱，这听起来像是一个掩护，但警方仍在考虑蒙大拿州对他是否具有重要意义。他还承认自己很紧张。难道黄道十二宫杀手并不是他所表现出的那种自信的杀手吗？那个问题和许多其他问题的答案仍然是个谜。已知的是，他变得越来越残忍和暴力。
His arsenal had increased to include a knife and rope. He had made himself a striking uniform, which Brian Hartnell described as carefully sewn and meticulously placed. But what was the point if he didn't plan to leave survivors who could describe it? Perhaps his motivation was to instill fear in his victims, ensuring that the last thing they ever saw was a dark hooded figure with a crosshair emblazoned across his chest. Or perhaps the outfit was linked to his self-aggrandizing fantasies. Whatever the reason, the Zodiac was receiving the notoriety he craved. His crimes were making headlines, as police chased a killer whose pattern of behavior was as unclear as his motive.
他的武器库增加了刀和绳子。他为自己制作了一套引人注目的制服，布莱恩·哈特内尔将其描述为缝制精细且放置得一丝不苟。但如果他不打算留下能描述这套制服的幸存者，那又有什么意义呢？也许他的动机是在受害者心中灌输恐惧，确保他们最后看到的是一个胸前印有十字准星的黑色连帽身影。或者这套服装与他自我膨胀的幻想有关。无论原因是什么，黄道十二宫杀手都获得了他渴望的恶名。他的罪行登上了头条，而警方则在追捕一个行为模式和动机同样模糊不清的杀手。
Investigators were flooded with tip-offs and struggled to keep up with leads. One suspect was investigated after speaking about Deelodge Prison. Another was interviewed for having a crosshair tattoo. A man who was shot by police during a hostage crisis used his dying breaths to gasp. I'm Zodiac. That's me. But it was later determined that he was a troubled individual struggling with substance abuse. Psychics muddied efforts with dubious visions, while the police were flooded with calls from pranksters purporting to be the Zodiac. Detectives travelled interstate, examined other murders for links, compared handwriting samples, and checked alibis.
调查人员被举报信息淹没，难以跟进线索。一名嫌疑人在谈论迪洛奇监狱后受到调查。另一人因有十字准星纹身而接受讯问。一名在人质危机中被警察击毙的男子在临终前喘息着说：“我是黄道十二宫。就是我。”但后来确定他是一个饱受药物滥用困扰的麻烦人物。通灵者用可疑的幻象搅浑了调查工作，而警方则被自称是黄道十二宫杀手的恶作剧者的电话淹没。侦探们跨州旅行，检查其他谋杀案以寻找联系，比对笔迹样本，并核实不在场证明。
As September gave way to October, newspapers ran frightening headlines warning of the danger. This type of person could strike today or tomorrow one article cautioned. He's not run of the mill. He's a real psychopathic killer. Citizens were advised to steer clear of remote areas and told to travel in groups. Couples in particular were warned to be careful. Meanwhile, on a street corner in San Francisco, the Zodiac killer raised his arm and flagged down an approaching taxi. The night of Saturday, October 11, 1969, two weeks after the murder of Cecilia Shepard in San Francisco, California. 29-year-old Paul Stein said goodbye to his wife Claudia.
随着9月进入10月，报纸刊登了警告危险的惊人标题。一篇文章警告说：“这种人今天或明天就可能发动袭击。他不是普通人。他是一个真正的精神病杀手。”市民被建议远离偏远地区，并被告知结伴出行。情侣们尤其被警告要小心。与此同时，在旧金山的一个街角，黄道十二宫杀手举起手臂，拦下了一辆出租车。1969年10月11日星期六晚上，在塞西莉亚·谢泼德于加利福尼亚州旧金山遇害两周后。29岁的保罗·斯泰恩与妻子克劳迪娅告别。
By 8.45pm, he was behind the wheel of the taxi he drove for the Yellow Cab Company. It was a relatively new gig. Paul was completing his PhD in English and had turned to cab driving to make ends meet. Studying during the day and working at night was exhausting, but Paul was no stranger to hard work. A conscientious man with a sharp intellect that had earned him the nickname of Einstein, Paul was determined to make the arrangement work. His first customer was waiting near Pier 64 at Bayfront Park. Paul drove them to the San Francisco airport where he then received another job from his dispatcher. There was a customer waiting to be picked up at an apartment downtown on 9th Street.
晚上8点45分，他坐进了为黄牌出租车公司驾驶的出租车驾驶座。这是一份相对较新的工作。保罗正在攻读英语博士学位，为了维持生计而转行开出租车。白天学习晚上工作令人筋疲力尽，但保罗对辛勤工作并不陌生。作为一个认真且拥有敏锐头脑的人，他赢得了“爱因斯坦”的绰号，保罗决心让这种安排行得通。他的第一位顾客在海滨公园的64号码头附近等待。保罗开车送他们去了旧金山机场，随后从调度员那里接到了另一份工作。有一位顾客在市中心第9街的一间公寓等待接载。
Paul accepted the fare and began the 12-mile drive north back into the city. By this point, it was just after 9.45pm. As he neared the intersection of Mason and Geary Streets in the Tenderloin neighborhood, Paul caught sight of someone waving him down. He pulled over. The man asked if Paul could take him to the intersection of Washington and Maple Streets in the affluent neighborhood of Presidio Heights. Paul thought about it for a second. It was approximately a 3-mile trip in the same direction as 9th Street. He figured he could drop this man off on the way and still make it to collect his next passenger in time.
保罗接受了这笔生意，开始向北行驶12英里回到市区。此时，时间刚过晚上9点45分。当他接近田德隆区梅森街和吉里街的交叉口时，保罗看到有人向他招手。他靠边停车。那名男子问保罗是否能带他去富裕的普雷西迪奥高地社区的华盛顿街和枫树街交叉口。保罗考虑了一秒钟。这是一段大约3英里的路程，与去第9街的方向相同。他想他可以在路上放下这个人，并及时赶去接下一位乘客。
Paul accepted the fare, making note of it in his logbook. The passenger hopped in and closed the door behind him. Paul put his indicator on and pulled back into the street. He weaved his cab through the treeline streets of Presidio Heights, past the stately homes the area was known for. As he neared the corner of Washington and Cherry Streets, a block further than his passenger's original destination, his cab suddenly rolled to a stop. The engine idled. Paul Stines slumped down in his seat, flopping towards the passenger side. Blood snaked down his face and onto his torso.
保罗接受了这笔生意，并在日志中做了记录。乘客跳上车，关上了身后的车门。保罗打开转向灯，重新驶入街道。他驾驶出租车穿过普雷西迪奥高地绿树成荫的街道，经过该地区著名的庄严住宅。当他接近华盛顿街和樱桃街的拐角处，即比乘客最初目的地远一个街区的地方时，他的出租车突然停了下来。发动机空转。保罗·斯泰恩瘫倒在座位上，向乘客一侧倒去。鲜血顺着他的脸流下，滴在躯干上。
The single bullet fired at close range to the right side of his head had killed him instantly. He didn't even have time to turn the meter off. Sitting in the passenger seat with the body of Paul Stines draped across his lap, the zodiac killer rifled through his victim's pockets. Then he pulled out a piece of fabric and methodically wiped down the car's interior. Stepping out of the vehicle, he turned his attention to the outside, rubbing the cloth carefully across the exterior paintwork. Satisfied with his cleanup, the zodiac straightened up and casually walked away down Cherry Street. What he didn't know was that he was being watched by three teenage siblings who had gathered at the upstairs window of their nearby home. While they didn't witness the shooting, they saw what the killer did after.
近距离射向他头部右侧的一颗子弹当场夺去了他的生命。他甚至没有时间关掉计价器。黄道十二宫杀手坐在乘客座位上，保罗·斯泰恩的尸体横在他的膝盖上，他在受害者的口袋里翻找。然后他掏出一块布，有条不紊地擦拭车内。走出车外，他将注意力转向外部，小心翼翼地用布擦拭车身漆面。对清理工作感到满意后，黄道十二宫杀手挺直身子，漫不经心地沿着樱桃街走开了。他不知道的是，他被三名聚集在附近家中楼上窗户的青少年兄妹看到了。虽然他们没有目睹枪击过程，但他们看到了凶手之后所做的一切。
They quickly phoned police, describing the perpetrator as between 35 and 45 years old, about 5'10 and 190 pounds, with a pointy stomach and a reddish-blonde crew card. He was wearing horn-rimmed eyeglasses and dressed unremarkably in trousers and a jacket. Officers Donald Fowke and Eric Zelms were on patrol east of Presidio when they received word of the attack and a description of the perpetrator. They raced towards the scene at Washington and Cherry, keeping their eyes peeled for a suspect as described. They soon spotted someone. A stocky, middle-aged white male with a light-colored crew card. Standing at about 5'10, the man walked slowly with his head bent down, not appearing to be in any hurry. Curiously, he matched the suspect's description to a tee, except that he was white.
他们迅速打电话给警察，将肇事者描述为35到45岁，身高约5英尺10英寸，体重190磅，有着尖尖的肚子和红金色的平头。他戴着角质框眼镜，穿着普通的裤子和夹克。唐纳德·福克警官和埃里克·泽尔姆斯警官在普雷西迪奥以东巡逻时，收到了袭击的消息和肇事者的描述。他们冲向华盛顿街和樱桃街的现场，睁大眼睛寻找描述中的嫌疑人。他们很快发现了一个人。一个身材敦实、中年白人男性，留着浅色平头。身高约5英尺10英寸，那人低着头慢慢走着，看起来并不着急。奇怪的是，他与嫌疑人的描述完全吻合，只是他是白人。
The dispatcher had specifically said the offender was a black male. As the man didn't fit the profile, Officer Fowke and Zelms continued on. Upon arriving at the crime scene, officers found Paul Stein lying in a semi-supine position across the front seat with his head resting on the floor. Both he and the front compartment of the cab were soaked in blood. The three teenage siblings who had witnessed the aftermath of the shooting were interviewed at the scene. When they described the attacker as a white male, the questioning officer was confused. Weren't they on the lookout for a black suspect? Realizing the dispatcher had made a grave error, the officer immediately radioed in to have the broadcast corrected.
调度员明确表示罪犯是一名黑人男性。由于该男子不符合特征，福克警官和泽尔姆斯警官继续前行。到达犯罪现场后，警官们发现保罗·斯泰恩半仰着躺在前座上，头靠在地板上。他和出租车的前部都被鲜血浸透了。在现场采访了目睹枪击事件后果的三名青少年兄妹。当他们将袭击者描述为白人男性时，询问的警官感到困惑。他们不是在寻找一名黑人嫌疑人吗？意识到调度员犯了一个严重的错误，警官立即通过无线电要求更正广播。
He then walked north along Cherry Street, eyes peeled for anyone who looked like the shooter. But the streets were quiet. Not only was there no one who matched the suspect's description, there weren't even any witnesses around to question. Continuing east along Jackson Street, the officer passed the man out walking his dog but didn't see anyone else noteworthy. When word reached officers Donald Fowke and Derek Zelms that the shooter was actually a white male, they were stunned. They had just passed by a man who matched the perpetrator's description in every way other than the colour of his skin. Realizing they might have inadvertently driven right by the killer, Officer Fowke sped off towards the Presidio War playground, believing the man probably headed there after turning onto Maple Street. The area was surrounded by dense foliage.
他随后沿着樱桃街向北走，仔细寻找任何看起来像枪手的人。但街道很安静。不仅没有人符合嫌疑人的描述，甚至连可以询问的目击者都没有。沿着杰克逊街继续向东走，警官经过一名遛狗的男子，但没有看到其他值得注意的人。当唐纳德·福克警官和德里克·泽尔姆斯警官得知枪手实际上是白人男性时，他们惊呆了。他们刚刚经过一名除了肤色外，在各方面都符合肇事者描述的男子。意识到他们可能无意中开车经过了凶手，福克警官加速驶向普雷西迪奥战争游乐场，认为那人在转入枫树街后可能去了那里。该地区被茂密的植被包围。
Officer Fowke couldn't say anything through the dark. A large-scale search commenced. A spotlight scanned the darkened streets, alleyways and parklands as police swarmed the area in patrol cars and on motorbikes. Some paced the streets with sniffer dogs in tow. But the killer was long gone. Paul Stein's logbook indicated that the killer's destination had been the corner of Washington and Maple Street. The intersection was guarded by high trees that obstructed the views from residential windows, making it a safe place to pull off the murder without witnesses. It was also only one block from the Presidio War playground which would have provided a quick escape route.
福克警官在黑暗中什么也看不见。大规模搜捕开始了。探照灯扫过黑暗的街道、小巷和公园，警察们乘坐巡逻车和摩托车蜂拥而至。一些人带着嗅探犬在街上踱步。但凶手早已逃之夭夭。保罗·斯泰恩的日志显示，凶手的目的地是华盛顿街和枫树街的拐角处。交叉路口被高大的树木遮挡，阻挡了住宅窗户的视线，使其成为一个可以在没有目击者的情况下实施谋杀的安全地点。它距离普雷西迪奥战争游乐场也只有一个街区，这本可以提供一条快速逃生路线。
However, the location where Paul's cab was found was one block further west in a more exposed spot further from the park. Police wondered if Paul had perhaps overshot the intersection and the killer asked him to pull over at the next corner. Or maybe the shooter saw an unexpected witness at the original destination and changed his mind at the last moment. Another possibility was that Paul had still been driving when he was shot, forcing the gunman to take control of the vehicle as it careened out of control. There was very little evidence to help identify the suspect, yet police had a couple of clues to go on. Despite the killer's attempts to wipe the cab clean of evidence, several latent bloody fingerprints were lifted from the exterior of the vehicle. A pair of men's size 7 black leather gloves were also found inside the cab. These didn't belong to Paul. Examination of a spent Winchester Western bullet casing found on the passenger seat confirmed that it had been shot from a 9mm semi-automatic pistol.
然而，发现保罗出租车的地方在更西边一个街区，位置更暴露，距离公园更远。警方怀疑保罗是否可能开过了交叉路口，凶手让他停在下一个拐角处。或者枪手在最初的目的地看到了意想不到的目击者，并在最后一刻改变了主意。另一种可能性是，保罗在被枪击时仍在驾驶，迫使枪手在车辆失控时接管了控制权。几乎没有什么证据可以帮助识别嫌疑人，但警方有一些线索。尽管凶手试图擦掉出租车上的证据，但从车辆外部提取了几枚潜在的血指纹。车内还发现了一副男式7码黑色皮手套。这些不属于保罗。对在乘客座位上发现的一枚已发射的温彻斯特西部子弹壳的检查证实，它是从一把9毫米半自动手枪中射出的。
The killer had also taken Paul's wallet and car keys before fleeing the scene. This indicated to police that the shooting was nothing more than a violent robbery and there was no reason to believe otherwise. The three teenagers who'd seen the killer worked with a police artist to create a suspect sketch. Officer Fowke later helped complete a second composite based on the man he'd passed near the crime scene. The two faces were remarkably similar. Soon, both were on display in police stations across the state, printed side by side on wanted posters. Two days after Paul's murder, Carol Fisher-Cottes was sitting at her desk at the San Francisco Chronicle newspaper. She worked as the letters editor and it was her job to sort through correspondence sent by readers.
凶手在逃离现场前还拿走了保罗的钱包和车钥匙。这向警方表明，枪击事件不过是一起暴力抢劫，没有理由相信其他情况。看到凶手的三名青少年与警方画像师合作绘制了一张嫌疑人素描。福克警官后来协助完成了第二张基于他在犯罪现场附近经过的那名男子的合成图。两张脸非常相似。很快，两者都在全州的警察局展出，并排印在通缉令海报上。保罗遇害两天后，卡罗尔·费舍尔-科特斯正坐在旧金山纪事报的办公桌前。她担任信件编辑，她的工作是整理读者寄来的信件。
As she flicked through the mail that had arrived that day, she spotted an unusual envelope. In the top left hand corner where a return address was usually printed, someone had drawn a small crosshair symbol. Carol opened the envelope and, to her alarm, a strip of bloodied cloth fell out onto the desk. She looked inside the envelope and saw a single sheet of paper. It was a brief handwritten letter that read, This is the Zodiac speaking. I am the murderer of the taxi driver over by Washington and Maple Street last night. To prove this, here is a bloodstained piece of his shirt.
当她翻阅当天收到的邮件时，她发现了一个不寻常的信封。在通常印有回信地址的左上角，有人画了一个小小的十字准星符号。卡罗尔打开信封，令她惊恐的是，一条带血的布片掉到了桌子上。她往信封里看去，看到了一张纸。这是一封简短的手写信，上面写着：“我是黄道十二宫。我就是昨晚在华盛顿街和枫树街附近谋杀出租车司机的凶手。为了证明这一点，这是他衬衫上的一块血迹斑斑的碎片。”
I am the same man who did in the people in the North Bay area. The San Francisco police could have caught me last night if they had searched the park properly instead of holding road races with their motorcycles seeing who could make the most noise. The car drivers should have just parked their cars and sat there quietly, waiting for me to come out of cover. School children make nice targets. I think I shall wipe out a school bus some morning. Just shoot out the front tyre and then pick off the kitties as they come bouncing out. The letter was signed off with the same crosshair symbol that appeared on the envelope. Law enforcement officials were notified about the Zodiac's latest confession and took possession of the letter.
我就是那个在北湾地区杀人的凶手。如果旧金山警方昨晚能好好搜查公园，而不是开着摩托车在那儿比谁的噪音大，他们本可以抓住我的。那些开车的人应该直接把车停好，静静地坐在车里，等着我从掩体里出来。小学生是很好的目标。我想哪天早上我要毁掉一辆校车。只要打爆前轮胎，然后等那些小家伙蹦出来时把他们一个个干掉。这封信的落款处画着和信封上一样的十字准星符号。执法部门收到了“黄道十二宫”最新的供词，并扣押了这封信。
Given that Paul Stein's murder had been classed as a violent robbery, detectives hadn't considered any links to the Zodiac killer. So far, he'd only confessed to murders involving young couples in isolated locales. Because the Zodiac had been particularly brutal towards his female victims, criminal analysts theorized that he had a particular hatred for young women. A male cab driver killed at work didn't fit with his ammo. Additionally, detectives weren't even aware that a piece of Paul Stein's shirt was missing. No one had noticed this detail when bagging his clothing as evidence.
由于保罗·斯坦的谋杀案被归类为暴力抢劫，侦探们并没有考虑其与“黄道十二宫”杀手之间的任何联系。到目前为止，他只承认了涉及偏僻地区年轻情侣的谋杀案。由于“黄道十二宫”对女性受害者特别残忍，犯罪分析师推测他对年轻女性有特殊的仇恨。一名在工作中被杀的男性出租车司机并不符合他的作案手法。此外，侦探们甚至不知道保罗·斯坦的衬衫少了一块。在将他的衣服作为证据装袋时，没有人注意到这个细节。
They recovered Paul's shirt from the morgue and compared it to the strip of blooded cloth sent to the Chronicle. It was a perfect match. However, it appeared the killer had taken more fabric that was still unaccounted for. A handwriting expert for the FBI compared this letter with the others sent by the Zodiac killer and deemed that all had likely been written by the same person. With another Zodiac murder confirmed, criminal analysts now had more information to work with. They noticed how the killer's letters were peppered with misspelled words and grammatical errors. He seemed intelligent, so these mistakes suggested he lacked a formal education.
他们从停尸房找回了保罗的衬衫，并将其与寄给《纪事报》的那块带血的布条进行了比对。完全吻合。然而，凶手似乎还拿走了更多尚未找到的布料。联邦调查局的一名笔迹专家将这封信与“黄道十二宫”杀手寄出的其他信件进行了比对，认为所有信件很可能出自同一人之手。随着又一起“黄道十二宫”谋杀案得到证实，犯罪分析师现在有了更多可供研究的信息。他们注意到凶手的信件中充斥着拼写错误和语法错误。他看起来很聪明，所以这些错误表明他缺乏正规教育。
Though, it was also possible he was deliberately making mistakes, just to throw authorities off track. Another common thread was the fact that all of his crimes seemed to occur by bodies of water or in places with water-themed names. None of his crimes appeared personally motivated. It seemed that all victims had simply been in the wrong place at the wrong time. This was extremely concerning, given that the window between his attacks was narrowing. After shooting David Faraday and Betty Lou Jensen, almost seven months passed before the Zodiac killer struck again. Then, there were only three months between his attacks against Michael Majo and Darlene Farron and Brian Hartnell and Cecilia Shepard. Paul Stein's attack came exactly two weeks later.
不过，也有可能他是故意犯错，只是为了误导当局。另一个共同点是，他所有的犯罪似乎都发生在水体附近或地名与水有关的地方。他的犯罪似乎都没有个人动机。所有的受害者似乎都只是在错误的时间出现在了错误的地点。考虑到他作案的间隔时间正在缩短，这非常令人担忧。在枪杀大卫·法拉第和贝蒂·卢·詹森后，过了近七个月“黄道十二宫”杀手才再次作案。然后，他袭击迈克尔·马乔和达琳·法伦，以及布莱恩·哈特内尔和塞西莉亚·谢泼德之间仅隔了三个月。保罗·斯坦遇袭则是在两周后。
If he continued following this pattern, it seemed likely that another murder was imminent. When newspapers reported on the Zodiac's latest letter, they strategically declined to mention the threat he'd made about killing schoolchildren. California's residents were panicked enough, and they didn't want the Zodiac to get any more satisfaction. That all changed on October 16, five days after Paul Stein's murder, when the Los Angeles Times decided to make the detail public. As expected, the result was widespread panic. On the afternoon of October 20, a couple was out walking with their eight-year-old daughter in the northern California town of Ucaya. As the trio strolled along the quiet back road of Lake Mendocino Drive, a light-colored car drove by. The driver threw a twig out the window towards them.
如果他继续遵循这种模式，很可能很快就会发生另一起谋杀案。当报纸报道“黄道十二宫”的最新信件时，他们策略性地没有提及他关于杀害小学生的威胁。加州居民已经够恐慌了，他们不想让“黄道十二宫”得到更多的满足感。这一切在10月16日，即保罗·斯坦遇害五天后发生了变化，当时《洛杉矶时报》决定将这一细节公之于众。不出所料，结果引发了广泛的恐慌。10月20日下午，一对夫妇带着他们八岁的女儿在加州北部的尤卡亚镇散步。当三人沿着门多西诺湖大道那条安静的后路漫步时，一辆浅色的汽车开了过去。司机从窗户向他们扔了一根树枝。
Attached was a piece of paper. Written on it in crude handwriting were the words, Your Next, Zee. The following day, a San Francisco Bay Area newspaper received a phone call from someone claiming to be the Zodiac. He issued a harrowing warning. He was planning to shoot children as they traveled on school buses. Both incidents were reported, and law enforcement agencies were immediately on high alert. The police and California's highway patrol began surveilling all school buses in the area.
上面系着一张纸。上面用粗糙的笔迹写着：“下一个就是你，Zee”。第二天，旧金山湾区的一家报纸接到一个自称是“黄道十二宫”的人打来的电话。他发出了令人毛骨悚然的警告。他计划在孩子们乘坐校车时开枪射杀他们。这两起事件都被报道了，执法机构立即进入高度戒备状态。警方和加州公路巡警开始监视该地区所有的校车。
Some even had officers on board, ready to respond if necessary. But there were no attacks. It was becoming abundantly clear that the media obsession had spurred hoaxes and attention seekers into action, prompting false confessions and copycats. Some individuals developed an unhealthy fixation with the case, including one man from Montana who was convinced he was going to be a victim. I left California because it got too hot for me, an individual claiming to be the Zodiac told an Oklahoma radio program. The Zodiac was a title many were willing to adopt for their own reasons, while the actual killer remained silent. To coax the Zodiac killer out of hiding, California's Attorney General appealed for him to come forward by promising to provide help and protection.
有些车上甚至有警官随行，准备在必要时做出反应。但并没有发生袭击。显而易见，媒体的痴迷已经促使恶作剧者和寻求关注的人采取行动，导致了虚假的供词和模仿犯罪。一些人对这个案件产生了不健康的执念，包括一名来自蒙大拿州的男子，他坚信自己会成为受害者。“我离开了加州，因为那里对我来说太危险了，”一名自称是“黄道十二宫”的人告诉俄克拉荷马州的一个广播节目。许多人出于各自的原因愿意采用“黄道十二宫”这个称号，而真正的凶手却保持沉默。为了诱使“黄道十二宫”杀手现身，加州总检察长呼吁他自首，并承诺提供帮助和保护。
Editors at the San Francisco Examiner also ran a direct message to the Zodiac on the paper's front page. It read, in part, Five people are dead. Let there be no more killings. You are being hunted everywhere in the state and nation. You are alone in this world. You can share your secrets with no one. We ask that you give yourself up to the examiner. We offer you no protection and no sympathy, but we do offer you fair treatment, the assurance of medical help, and the full benefits of your legal rights. And we offer to tell your story. There was no response.
《旧金山考察家报》的编辑们也在报纸头版刊登了给“黄道十二宫”的直接信息。内容部分写道：“五个人已经死了。不要再有杀戮了。你在全州和全国范围内都被追捕。在这个世界上你是孤独的。你不能与任何人分享你的秘密。我们要求你向《考察家报》自首。我们不提供保护，也不提供同情，但我们提供公平的对待、医疗救助的保证以及你法律权利的全部利益。我们还提议讲述你的故事。”没有回应。
Paul Stein's brother Joe also directly addressed the Zodiac when he offered himself up as bait. Joe was sure that he could take the killer down, explaining that he was an Army and Air Force veteran capable of overpowering a coward like the Zodiac, even without a weapon. Giving specific details as to where the killer could find him, Joe said, I work at the Richfield service station at 706 Sutter Street in Modesto. I start at 7am. I go to lunch at the walk-in chicken in a shopping centre two blocks away, riding a bicycle along Sutter Street and leaving the station at noon each day. I go back to the service station and work until five. Let him come and get me. Other residents and business owners in the neighbourhood were less than thrilled about Joe's challenge.
保罗·斯坦的兄弟乔也直接向“黄道十二宫”喊话，提出自己作为诱饵。乔确信他能制服凶手，并解释说他是一名陆军和空军退伍军人，即使没有武器也能制服像“黄道十二宫”这样的懦夫。乔给出了凶手可以找到他的具体细节，他说：“我在莫德斯托萨特街706号的里奇菲尔德加油站工作。我早上7点上班。我每天中午离开加油站，骑自行车沿着萨特街去两个街区外的快餐店吃午饭。我回到加油站工作到五点。让他来抓我吧。”社区里的其他居民和店主对乔的挑战并不感到兴奋。
They feared it would draw the serial killer to their community and place them in danger. However, their concern was unwarranted. The Zodiac didn't take Joe up on his offer. On the night of Saturday, October 18, a lone car sat in the parking lot of Vallejo's Blue Rock Springs Park, close by to where Darlene Farron and Michael Majo had been shot. It was nearing 2am when a second vehicle approached. A 1964 Greenish Grey Chevrolet station wagon pulled into the parking lot and drove towards the other car. The Chevrolet stopped and its engine switched off. A middle-aged man of average height and build exited the vehicle. He walked right up to the neighbouring car. Just then, two undercover officers sprang into action.
他们担心这会把连环杀手引到他们的社区，使他们处于危险之中。然而，他们的担忧是多余的。“黄道十二宫”并没有接受乔的提议。10月18日星期六晚上，一辆孤零零的汽车停在瓦列霍蓝石泉公园的停车场里，靠近达琳·法伦和迈克尔·马乔被枪杀的地方。快到凌晨2点时，第二辆车靠近了。一辆1964年的灰绿色雪佛兰旅行车驶入停车场，朝另一辆车开去。雪佛兰停了下来，引擎熄火了。一名中等身材、中等体型的中年男子下了车。他径直走向旁边的车。就在这时，两名卧底警官采取了行动。
They had planted the first car there as bait, hoping to lure the Zodiac into attempting another attack. Their plan appeared to have worked. But the driver of the Chevrolet explained that he was a Navy employee stationed on Treasure Island in San Francisco. He was on his way to Lake Berryessa, but had gotten lost. Upon seeing the car at Blue Rock Springs Park, he decided to ask for directions. With no reason to doubt him, the officers let the man go and resumed their covert positions. They stayed there for the rest of the night, but nobody else approached the bait car. The Zodiac clearly wasn't falling for it.
他们把第一辆车停在那里作为诱饵，希望能引诱“黄道十二宫”再次发动袭击。他们的计划似乎奏效了。但雪佛兰的司机解释说，他是驻扎在旧金山金银岛的一名海军雇员。他正要去伯耶萨湖，但迷路了。看到蓝石泉公园里的车，他决定问路。由于没有理由怀疑他，警官们放走了那个人，并恢复了他们的隐蔽位置。他们在那里待了剩下的时间，但没有其他人靠近诱饵车。显然，“黄道十二宫”并没有上当。
Despite their initial hope, the tactic was unsuccessful and no further stakeouts were planned. Investigators turned their focus to the guns used during the attacks. In total, the killer had used three different firearms. A .22 caliber weapon had been used on David and Betty Lou, while two different 9mm weapons were used during the attacks on Michael and Darlene and Paul Stein. The one used to kill Paul was a semi-automatic that required ammunition only available from specialised gun dealers. Only 143 9mm firearms similar to those used in the Zodiac attacks had been sold in San Francisco over the last three years. Investigators hunted down the buyer's gun applications and compared their handwriting to that on the Zodiac letters.
尽管最初抱有希望，但该策略并不成功，也没有计划进一步的蹲守。调查人员将重点转向了袭击中使用的枪支。凶手总共使用了三种不同的枪支。大卫和贝蒂·卢遇害时使用的是.22口径武器，而在袭击迈克尔、达琳和保罗·斯坦时使用了两种不同的9毫米武器。杀死保罗的那把是半自动手枪，需要专门的枪支经销商才能买到的弹药。过去三年里，旧金山仅售出了143把与“黄道十二宫”袭击中使用的类似的9毫米枪支。调查人员追查了购枪申请，并将他们的笔迹与“黄道十二宫”信件上的笔迹进行了比对。
No matches were found. It was close to midnight on Tuesday, October 21, 1969, when a phone rang at Oakland Police Department, 12.5 miles east of San Francisco. An officer answered and was greeted by a male on the other line who introduced himself as the Zodiac killer. He then made a strange request. He wanted one of two specific defense attorneys to appear on San Francisco talk show, the Jim Dunbar show, the following morning. If this request was granted, the caller said he would be open to negotiating live on air. To prove he was genuine, he provided knowledge about the Zodiac case that police deemed to be legitimate.
没有发现匹配项。1969年10月21日星期二午夜时分，旧金山以东12.5英里的奥克兰警察局电话响了。一名警官接听电话，电话那头的一名男子自称是“黄道十二宫”杀手。他提出了一个奇怪的要求。他希望两位特定辩护律师中的一位能在第二天早上出现在旧金山的脱口秀节目《吉姆·邓巴秀》上。如果这个要求得到满足，打电话的人说他愿意在直播中进行谈判。为了证明他是真的，他提供了警方认为合法的关于“黄道十二宫”案件的知识。
Investigators agreed to the caller's demands. One of the attorneys he wanted to speak to was Melvin Belier. He was famous for defending Jack Ruby, an American nightclub owner who killed presidential assassin Lee Harvey Oswald. Belier agreed to appear on the show. The next morning, the Jim Dunbar show went live to air at seven o'clock. All the other guests on the show were canceled as Dunbar and Belier made small talk. After 49 minutes, the phone finally rang. The caller identified himself as the Zodiac, but Belier asked for another name they could use.
调查人员同意了打电话者的要求。他想与之交谈的律师之一是梅尔文·贝利。他因辩护杰克·鲁比而闻名，杰克·鲁比是一名杀害总统刺客李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德的美国夜总会老板。贝利同意参加节目。第二天早上，吉姆·邓巴秀在七点钟直播。节目中的所有其他嘉宾都被取消了，邓巴和贝利进行了闲聊。49分钟后，电话终于响了。打电话的人自称是“黄道十二宫”，但贝利要求换一个他们可以使用的名字。
He told them to call him Sam. Talk to us. Just tell us what's going on inside you right now, Sam. I have headaches. How long have you had those headaches, Sam? In a long time? Since I killed a kid. If it all boils down to the question of you're giving yourself up if you could be assured that you wouldn't get capital punishment for myself.
他告诉他们叫他萨姆。“跟我们谈谈。告诉我们你现在内心在想什么，萨姆。”“我头疼。”“萨姆，你头疼多久了？很久了吗？”“自从我杀了一个孩子。如果这一切归结为你是否会自首的问题，如果你能被保证不会被判死刑的话……”
I don't want to give myself up. So when I kill those kids... In an effort to avoid having the call traced, Sam kept hanging up and calling back minutes later. In total, he phoned 15 times over the course of two hours. Before ending one call, Sam said, I'm getting one of my headaches now. I've got to kill. I've got to kill.
“我不想自首。所以当我杀那些孩子的时候……”为了避免电话被追踪，萨姆不断挂断电话，几分钟后再打过来。在两个小时内，他总共打了15次电话。在结束其中一个电话前，萨姆说：“我现在又开始头疼了。我必须杀人。我必须杀人。”
At one point, he threatened to jump off the roof of a hotel unless Belier agreed to meet him there. While off air, Belier convinced Sam to meet him elsewhere. They arranged to meet at 10.30 that morning at the St. Vincent de Paul's office building on Mission Street. Belier and Dunbar went to the location with high hopes. Word about the meeting got out and camera crews and curious onlookers flocked to the area hoping to witness some action. The police arrived half an hour later, but the Zodiac never showed up. Recordings of the calls were played to three people who had heard the Zodiac's voice. These were Lake Berryessa survivor Brian Hartnell and the two police dispatchers Nancy Slover and David Slade.
有一次，他威胁说要从一家酒店的屋顶跳下去，除非贝利同意在那里见他。在节目外，贝利说服萨姆在别处见面。他们约定当天上午10点30分在米申街的圣文森特·德·保罗办公大楼见面。贝利和邓巴怀着极大的希望前往该地点。关于这次会面的消息传开了，摄像组和好奇的围观者涌向该地区，希望能目睹一些动静。警察半小时后赶到，但“黄道十二宫”从未露面。电话录音被播放给三位听过“黄道十二宫”声音的人听。他们是伯耶萨湖幸存者布莱恩·哈特内尔和两名警察调度员南希·斯洛弗和戴维·斯莱德。
None of them thought Sam sounded like the Zodiac. With no evidence to convince them otherwise, police suspected that the calls had been a hoax. On Saturday, November 8, another envelope arrived at the San Francisco Chronicle with the words, please rush to the editor, written on both sides. It had been almost four weeks since the Zodiac had made contact. He was now attempting to be funny by submitting a greeting card that parodied a popular television commercial of the time. On the front was an illustration of a fountain pen dripping in blood and inside was a cipher with 340 different characters. Accompanying the card was a handwritten letter that read,
他们都不认为萨姆听起来像“黄道十二宫”。由于没有证据让他们相信这一点，警方怀疑这些电话是恶作剧。11月8日星期六，另一个信封寄到了《旧金山纪事报》，两面都写着“请速交编辑”。距离“黄道十二宫”上次联系已经过去了近四周。他现在试图通过提交一张模仿当时流行电视广告的贺卡来搞笑。正面是一幅滴着血的钢笔插图，里面是一个包含340个不同字符的密码。随卡附上的一封手写信写道：
This is the Zodiac speaking. I thought you would need a good laugh before you hear the bad news. You won't get the news for a while yet. P.S. could you print this new cipher on your front page? I get awfully lonely when I am ignored. So lonely, I could do my thing. It was signed with the Zodiac's crosshair symbol followed by the words, December, July, August, September, October equals 7.
“我是‘黄道十二宫’。我想在听到坏消息之前，你需要好好笑一笑。你暂时还不会得到消息。附：你能把这个新密码印在头版吗？被忽视时我感到非常孤独。太孤独了，我可能会做我的事。”落款是“黄道十二宫”的十字准星符号，后面跟着“12月、7月、8月、9月、10月等于7”的字样。
This final line was explained the very next day when the San Francisco Chronicle received another letter that began. This is the Zodiac speaking. Up to the end of October I have killed seven people. I have grown rather angry with the police for their telling lies about me. So I shall change the way the collecting of slaves. I shall no longer announce to anyone. When I commit my murders they shall look like routine robberies, killings of anger and a few fake accidents, etc.
最后一行在第二天得到了解释，当时《旧金山纪事报》收到了另一封信，开头写道：“我是‘黄道十二宫’。到10月底，我已经杀了七个人。我对警察关于我的谎言感到非常愤怒。所以我将改变收集奴隶的方式。我将不再向任何人宣布。当我犯下谋杀案时，它们看起来就像例行的抢劫、愤怒的杀戮和一些伪造的事故等。”
The police shall never catch me because I have been too clever for them. The Zodiac's claim that he'd killed seven people was confusing as he was only known to have taken the lives of five victims. He went on to boast that he avoided detection by wearing a disguise and coating his fingertips with airplane cement while committing his crimes. He also claimed to have wiped Paul Stein's cab down to leave the police with false clues. Then detailed a supposed encounter he'd had with two officers near the scene. Quote, Two cops pulled a goof about three minutes after I left the cab.
“警察永远抓不到我，因为我比他们聪明得多。”“黄道十二宫”声称他杀了七个人，这令人困惑，因为已知他只夺走了五名受害者的生命。他接着吹嘘说，他在犯罪时通过伪装和用飞机胶水涂抹指尖来避免被发现。他还声称擦拭了保罗·斯坦的出租车，给警方留下了错误的线索。然后详细描述了他曾在现场附近与两名警官的所谓相遇。引用：“我离开出租车大约三分钟后，两个警察搞砸了。
I was walking down the hill to the park when this cop car pulled up and one of them called me over and asked if I saw anyone acting suspicious or strange in the last five to ten minutes. And I said yes. There was this man who was running by waving a gun and the cops peeled rubber and went around the corner as I directed them. And I disappeared into the park a block and a half away, never to be seen again. Hey pig, doesn't it roll you up to have your nose rubbed in your boo-boos? The letter droned on for six pages.
我正走下山去公园，这时警车停了下来，其中一个叫住我，问我过去五到十分钟内是否看到有人行为可疑或奇怪。我说有。有一个人跑过去挥舞着枪，警察猛踩油门，按照我的指示绕过拐角。而我消失在了一个半街区外的公园里，再也没有被看见。嘿，猪猡，把你的鼻子按在你的错误里，这难道不让你感到羞耻吗？”这封信喋喋不休地写了六页。
Towards the end, the Zodiac provided accurate bomb-making instructions along with an illustration of a homemade incendiary device. He warned he was going to use this contraption to blow up a bus, adding that he could be storing it in his basement or at the site where he intended to detonate. On his trademark crosshair symbol, the Zodiac had added small X's at various points of the circle, which were believed to indicate various times of day. Editors for the San Francisco Chronicle published excerpts from the two most recent letters, but decided to omit the bomb threat for fear it would lead to panic.
在结尾处，“黄道十二宫”提供了准确的炸弹制造说明，并附上了自制燃烧装置的插图。他警告说他要用这个装置炸毁一辆公共汽车，并补充说他可能把它存放在地下室或他打算引爆的地点。在标志性的十字准星符号上，“黄道十二宫”在圆圈的各个点上添加了小X，据信这代表了一天中的不同时间。《旧金山纪事报》的编辑们发表了最近两封信的摘录，但决定删掉炸弹威胁，以免引起恐慌。
They also published the new cipher included with the greeting card, which was named the 340 cipher. It was a different code altogether from the original 408 cipher, and the editors hoped that amateur code breakers would be able to crack this one too. It was also forwarded to professional cryptologists at the FBI headquarters, the National Security Agency, and the Central Intelligence Agency. But no one was able to break the code. In December 1969, defence lawyer Melvin Beley travelled to the German city of Munich to attend a conference. While he was away, his housekeeper back in San Francisco forwarded all correspondence to his office
他们还发表了贺卡中包含的新密码，即“340密码”。这与最初的“408密码”完全不同，编辑们希望业余密码破译者也能破解这个密码。它也被转发给了联邦调查局总部、国家安全局和中央情报局的专业密码学家。但没有人能破解这个密码。1969年12月，辩护律师梅尔文·贝利前往德国慕尼黑参加会议。在他离开期间，他在旧金山的管家将所有信件转发到了他的办公室，
so his employees could check for important documents. When they returned to work after the Christmas break, they discovered an envelope postmarked December 20. Scribbled on the back in poor spelling was the message, Merry Christmas and New Year. One of Beley's colleagues opened the envelope. Inside was a blood-stained scrap of fabric along with a neatly handwritten letter that read, Dear Melvin, this is the Zodiac speaking. I wish you a happy Christmas. The one thing I ask of you is this, please help me.
以便他的员工可以检查重要文件。圣诞假期后他们回到工作岗位时，发现了一个邮戳为12月20日的信封。背面用糟糕的拼写潦草地写着：“圣诞快乐，新年快乐”。贝利的一位同事打开了信封。里面是一块带血的布料，还有一封整洁的手写信，上面写着：“亲爱的梅尔文，我是‘黄道十二宫’。祝你圣诞快乐。我请求你的一件事是，请帮帮我。
I cannot reach out for help because this thing in me won't let me. I am binding it extremely difficult to hold it in check. I am afraid I will lose control again and take my ninth and possibly tenth victim. Please help me, I am drowning. At the moment the children are safe from the bomb because it is so massive to dig in and the trigger mechanism required much work to get it adjusted just right. But if I hold back too long from number nine, I will lose all control of myself and set the bomb up. Please help me, I cannot remain in control for much longer.
我无法寻求帮助，因为我体内的这个东西不让我这样做。我发现很难控制它。我担心我会再次失去控制，夺走我的第九个甚至第十个受害者。请帮帮我，我快淹死了。目前孩子们是安全的，因为炸弹太大了，难以挖掘，触发机制需要大量工作才能调整得恰到好处。但如果我推迟第九个受害者太久，我就会完全失去控制，安装炸弹。请帮帮我，我无法再保持控制太久了。”
The envelope and its contents were passed along to authorities, who determined that the bloody fabric was another piece of Paul Stein's shirt. This, along with the fact that the Zodiac's bomb threat hadn't been released to the public, convinced them that the letter was genuine. Although it was significantly neater than the others, leading some to believe that the Zodiac wanted to impress Belai. It was difficult to tell whether the Zodiac was being sincere or sarcastic in his cries for help. Up until this point, he'd portrayed himself as a dangerous man not to be messed with,
信封及其内容被移交给当局，他们确定带血的布料是保罗·斯坦衬衫的另一部分。这一点，加上“黄道十二宫”的炸弹威胁没有向公众发布的事实，使他们确信这封信是真的。尽管它比其他的要整洁得多，导致一些人认为“黄道十二宫”想给贝利留下深刻印象。很难说“黄道十二宫”在求救时是真诚的还是讽刺的。直到这一点，他一直把自己描绘成一个不可招惹的危险人物，
but now he was coming across as vulnerable and desperate. It was also unclear what he wanted Belai to do with this information, as he hadn't specifically requested psychiatric or legal help. But the letter raised an even bigger question. At this point, the Zodiac had been linked to five murders, those of Betty Lou Jensen, David Faraday, Darlene Farron, Cecilia Shepard and Paul Stein. So who were the three other victims he was referring to? Were there more victims investigators hadn't yet linked him to?
但现在他表现得脆弱而绝望。也不清楚他希望贝利如何处理这些信息，因为他没有明确要求精神病学或法律援助。但这封信提出了一个更大的问题。此时，“黄道十二宫”已与五起谋杀案有关，即贝蒂·卢·詹森、大卫·法拉第、达琳·法伦、塞西莉亚·谢泼德和保罗·斯坦。那么他提到的另外三名受害者是谁？是否还有调查人员尚未将他联系起来的更多受害者？
Or was he simply taunting them? Belai appealed for the Zodiac to make further contact via an article in the San Francisco Chronicle. He offered to meet anywhere the Zodiac wanted and agree to any demands. On January 14, 1970, the phone rang at Belai's home in San Francisco. He was still overseas, so his housekeeper took the call. It was Sam, the same man who had called the Jim Dunbar show claiming to be the Zodiac. When he was told the lawyer wasn't available, Sam replied, I can't wait, it's my birthday.
还是他只是在嘲弄他们？贝利通过《旧金山纪事报》的一篇文章呼吁“黄道十二宫”进一步联系。他提议在“黄道十二宫”想要的任何地方见面，并同意任何要求。1970年1月14日，贝利在旧金山的家中电话响了。他还在海外，所以他的管家接了电话。是萨姆，那个曾打电话给《吉姆·邓巴秀》自称是“黄道十二宫”的人。当被告知律师不在时，萨姆回答说：“我等不及了，今天是我的生日。”
He then hung up the phone. Almost a month later on February 5, Sam called Jim Dunbar again. Police were alerted and Jim tried to keep Sam talking while detectives raced to the studios to listen in. By the time they arrived, Sam had hung up. The call hadn't been long enough to be traced. The calls from Sam also continued at Melvin Belai's residence, so the FBI set up a trace on the line. One call was eventually traced back to a mental health facility in Oakland. It had been made by an inpatient named Eric Wheel, who was an amateur photographer from the San Francisco Bay Area.
然后他挂断了电话。近一个月后的2月5日，萨姆再次致电吉姆·邓巴。警方接到警报，吉姆试图让萨姆保持通话，而侦探们则赶往演播室监听。当他们到达时，萨姆已经挂断了。通话时间不够长，无法追踪。萨姆的电话也继续打到梅尔文·贝利的住所，所以联邦调查局在电话线上设置了追踪。一个电话最终被追踪到奥克兰的一家心理健康机构。这是由一名叫埃里克·威尔的住院病人打出的，他是旧金山湾区的一名业余摄影师。
Recordings of Wheel's voice were played to those who had heard the real Zodiac speak, including Lake Berryessa survivor Brian Hartnell, and none thought they were the same person. Regardless, Weir was interviewed extensively and also provided fingerprints and handwriting samples. Investigators confirmed he was responsible for the hoax phone calls to the police department, the Jim Dunbar show, and Marvin Belai's residence. But he was ultimately ruled out as a suspect in the Zodiac killings. The real Zodiac never responded to Belai's public offer of assistance. As news of the Zodiac continued to dominate headlines in California, Los Angeles resident Donald Cheney couldn't shake an uneasy feeling. He'd recently been plagued by the memory of something that happened a couple of years earlier, and it was eating at his every thought. In January of 1968, Donald had been on a hunting trip with a friend.
威尔的声音录音被播放给那些听过真正的“黄道十二宫”说话的人听，包括伯耶萨湖幸存者布莱恩·哈特内尔，没有人认为他们是同一个人。无论如何，威尔接受了广泛的采访，并提供了指纹和笔迹样本。调查人员证实，他对警察局、《吉姆·邓巴秀》和马文·贝利住所的恶作剧电话负责。但他最终被排除在“黄道十二宫”谋杀案的嫌疑人之外。真正的“黄道十二宫”从未回应贝利公开提供的帮助。随着“黄道十二宫”的新闻继续占据加州的头条新闻，洛杉矶居民唐纳德·切尼无法摆脱一种不安的感觉。他最近一直被几年前发生的一件事的记忆所困扰，这让他每时每刻都在思考。1968年1月，唐纳德和一位朋友去旅行狩猎。
The two were chatting about a science fiction story when all of a sudden, Donald's friend turned to him and asked, Have you ever thought of hunting people? As Donald tried to process this disturbing question, his friend began describing the way he would carry out such an attack. He would go to a lover's lane armed with a revolver or pistol that was fitted with an aiming device and flashlight. He would then approach anyone in the vicinity and start shooting. Alternatively, he would shoot the tires of a school bus and then shoot each child as they came bouncing out of the bus. The crimes would have no motive, making it difficult for investigators to catch him. To amuse himself, he would then taunt detectives by sending them letters filled with red herrings.
两人正在聊一部科幻小说，突然，唐纳德的朋友转向他问道：“你有没有想过猎杀人类？”当唐纳德试图消化这个令人不安的问题时，他的朋友开始描述他将如何实施这样的袭击。他会带着装有瞄准装置和手电筒的左轮手枪或手枪去情人巷。然后他会接近附近的任何人并开始射击。或者，他会射击校车的轮胎，然后射杀每一个蹦出校车的孩子。这些犯罪将没有动机，使调查人员难以抓住他。为了自娱自乐，他会通过寄给他们充满误导信息的信件来嘲弄侦探。
While this information alone was enough to haunt Donald, there was one detail in particular that had his head spinning. His friend had said he would sign the letters with the name he'd taken a particular liking to. The Zodiac To be continued next week. . There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
虽然这些信息本身就足以让唐纳德感到困扰，但有一个细节让他头晕目眩。他的朋友说他会用他特别喜欢的名字来签署信件。黄道十二宫。下周继续。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。